So you have to connect with
them culturally and socially.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here
again, and today I want to
talk about workplace English.
Uh, if you enjoy these videos,
please subscribe, click on
the bell for notifications.
And if you're following me on a
podcast service, please leave a review.
So many people I know listen to
my, uh, videos, uh, or even as a
podcast to improve their English.
English is, whether we like it
or not, sort of the most widely
used international language.
So there is a need to
learn English for work.
This is particularly true of immigrants
to say Canada, the US, UK, Australia,
English-speaking countries who have a need
to work in the sort of mainstream economy,
therefore to use English or in the case of
Canada, French in the province of Quebec.
So...
and, and there are many, if we Google,
we look for, you know, professional
English business, English workplace
English, there are special programs
courses that are offered uh, to help
people improve their English for work.
But I have some general
sort of thoughts on this.
My only view is that to work in
English, the sort of technical
jargon, the technical vocabulary
that you need is rather limited, uh,
that can be learned quite easily.
And, uh, what I would do if I were say,
having to work in German, let's say,
or a Spanish or Chinese or Russian or
Japanese or Portuguese, then I would
find, you know, documents, uh, reports,
um, things of that nature, which have
the vocabulary, the technical vocabulary
that relates to my area of professional,
uh, you know, expertise or things that
I need, and I would read them and I
would, if I could find podcasts on
these subjects, I would listen to them.
I would save the words and
phrases that I need essentially
using something like LingQ.
I would bring them into LingQ
and then work them to get that,
uh, jargon, that turn of phrase,
the technical terms that I need.
That's the easy part.
The more difficult part is, because
if you work in a, an office or
you're interacting with customers
or suppliers, or you're dealing with
people in a working environment,
you are dealing with them socially.
You're dealing with them socially while
at work, you're dealing with them in
many situations socially after work.
So you have to connect with
them culturally and socially,
that's more difficult.
So I always say, you know, the
professional English, the business
English, that's the easy part.
Work on improving your social English.
And fortunately today there's an abundance
of sitcoms on YouTube on Netflix.
Uh, there's different ways we
can access these to get at the,
the phrasing that is being used.
Uh, you know, if we can get ourselves
to a stage where we actually get the
jokes, um, you know, even the fact
that we watch some of the popular TV
programs or see the most recent movies
gives us a subject of discussion that we
can share with our colleagues at work.
Um, but also we can acquire the
vocabulary and get a sense of, of the
culture to the extent that these sitcoms
reflect how people actually live.
It's a somewhat distorted impression.
Nevertheless, I find when I watch a sitcom
and in...you know, Turkish or whatever.
I have a feeling that I'm participating
in, in the life of these people, Turkish
people, if it's a family or whatever.
And I tend to prefer sitcoms with what
seems to be realistic people rather than,
you know, crime and car, car races, and
shooting and all this kind of stuff.
So, so we have to work even in
the workplace, we have to work
on our social English as well as
our, um, professional English.
Now, when it comes to sales
presentations or making a presentation
of any kind, I think it's, first
of all, you want to study people
who are effective at doing this.
And the interesting thing for those
people learning English is that there
is an abundance of podcasts on...
not only on every possible area of,
from marketing to technical issues to,
uh, you name it Bitcoin, I don't know.
There's, there's podcasts on everything.
Uh, and there's podcasts on history
and there's podcasts on whatever
subject you're interested in.
So I would definitely recommend
availing yourself of podcasts.
But also, uh, I'm sure, I don't
know if there are podcasts on how to
make a presentation, but there's a
lots of, I haven't Googled for it,
but if you Google for how to make a
presentation, you get lots of tips.
My suggestion is in any presentation I
have made, I use the sort of presentation
techniques of the ancient Greeks and
Romans the sort of rhetorical conventions.
And you can Google rhetoric and you
will see that they have a certain style.
You begin by...
you have to begin by making
people like you in a way and
establishing your credentials.
And then you tell a story
and then you can present some
counter-arguments to your story.
And then you want to finish
with an emotional appeal.
I mean, I've summarized it very
quickly, but I would definitely
recommend that you do some research
into how to present things effectively.
And there are a number of conflicting
theories of how to present effectively,
but these are techniques that you should
have because if you have a technique
that you're using for how you are going
to present, how you're going to make
yourself appear credible, how you're
going to lead the audience one way and
then lead them another way and then
conclude in some other way then you have
the feeling that you are in control.
And that is a very powerful
feeling when you are trying to
persuade people of something.
So to summarize then, uh, by all means,
uh, and, and once we're talking about
workplace English, in most cases,
we're talking about people who are
beyond that sort of beginner level.
These are people who have a certain
level in the language who need to
improve that level, but beyond that want
to feel comfortable in the workplace.
So my advice in summary is by all means
find technical documents, articles,
material, books, podcasts that you can
access in order to get the technical
jargon and phrasiology that you need.
Or for that matter, if you
have, if you have to write
papers, there are forms that...
or structures that should be used
in making, you know, presenting your
dissertation or whatever it might be, but
then make sure you put enough effort into
the social cultural language so that you
can be comfortable with your colleagues
at work, whether at work or after work.
And there are any number of ways you can
do that because nowadays there's just so
much material available on the internet.
Even if you don't live in say an
English-speaking country, you can
access that kind of environment
through Netflix, YouTube, and other,
you know, maybe presentations that
are available on, on the internet.
And finally, if you are in the situation
where you have to make sales presentations
doing a little bit of research on
effective, you know, speechmaking
and, and rhetoric, as I say, R H E T
O R I C, because the ancient Greeks
enrollment has really had a good approach.
It was a big part of, of their education.
And, uh, I think it's
very valuable even today.
So there you have it, uh, a brief
discussion on workplace English
and, uh, it is part of this
whole idea of effective output.
So I will leave a couple of videos where I
talk about using the language effectively.